[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir les proches des victimes de
la répression du régime d'alpha condé en
guinée réclament justice le procureur
général de conakry a lancé des
poursuites contre l'ancien président
pour assassinat actes de torture et
enlèvements nous écouterons les
témoignages des familles des victimes
dans ce journal la déscolarisation des
enfants au niger la pauvreté
l'insécurité pousse de plus en plus
d'enfants a quitté l'école et à être
exploité pour un salaire de misère
reportage de notre correspondant à
suivre dans ce journal
le burkina faso qui se met à la mode le
pays veut faire de la ouaga fashion week
un rendez vous incontournable sur le
continent mais l'insécurité croissante
rend les choses compliquées les détails
à la fin de cette édition
il continue à réclamer justice ces
guinéens qui ont été victimes de la
répression sanglante des manifestations
pendant le régime d'alpha condé le
procureur général de conakry a annoncé
début mai des poursuites contre l'ancien
président et plusieurs hauts
responsables pour assassinat actes de
torture et enlèvements sarah sakho et
malik diakité en rencontrer les familles
des victimes reportage
carrefour bambeto en banlieue de conakry
le lieu est tristement célèbre pour
avoir été le fief des manifestations
meurtrières qui ont marqué le régime
d'alpha condé a besoin vite à quelques
rues ce amusiez n'oubliera jamais ce
jour d'octobre 2020 à la veille de la
réélection d'alpha condé pour un
troisième mandat contesté
il affirme avoir perdu son fils unique
sous les balles des forces de l'autre
elle avait que 17 en deux mois cinq
jours l'enfant est sorti
en faisant coup d'oeil il y avait des
annales ou cultuelles on a tiré sur lui
s'il environ de ces jours ci à
l'adjectif duper par rené message du sud
comment tu peux pas donné quelqu'un qui
ne connaît pas
début avril la justice guinéenne a
engagé des poursuites contre alpha condé
et 26 au cadre de son régime l'ex chef
d'état et ses proches sont accusées
d'assassinats enlèvements et actes de
torture
de quoi redonner espoir aux familles de
l'association conapp aide assistent près
de 60 familles dans leur quête de
justice elle salue l'annoncé de cette
enquête et à une lueur d'espoir que
justice sera faite et que les gens
seront rétablis dans leurs droits même
si les remords ne vont pas de venir me
le savons mais qu'il y ait une
réhabilitation au moins des ses victimes
dans les droits ou rpg arc en ciel le
parti du président déchu les militants
crient à la machination politique
la justice guinéenne est une justice
téléguidé est une suisse orientée par le
pouvoir central qui a le cnrd les
valeurs de la démocratie nous allons la
défendre farouchement c'est pas un
téléphone militaire qui va nous dire que
non il faut pas des fois ça nous allons
nous battre jusqu'au bout
les organisations de défense des droits
de l'homme estime au moins à 200 le
nombre de morts causées par la
répression des manifestations dans le
pays entre 2019 et 2020
alors que les appels au boycott de
l'énergie russe se multiplient dans le
monde deux gigantesques bateaux citernes
plein de pétrole russe naviguent au
large des côtes sud africaines l'un
d'entre eux aurait à son bord plus de
deux millions de barils de pétrole
l'afrique du sud est officiellement
neutre dans la guerre entre la russie et
l'ukraine pretoria n'a jamais condamné
moscou les sud africains vont t'ils
aider les russes a acheté ou même a
stocké le brut qu'ils ont du mal à
vendre cette histoire fait grand bruit
la correspondance au cap de caroline
duel
des bateaux qui passent par les côtes du
cap il y en a beaucoup mais deux navires
ont particulièrement attiré l'attention
de bateaux citernes chargés de pétrole
russe le premier est passé par ses côtes
la semaine dernière en direction du sud
de cap agulla ce et le deuxième est
arrivé à jeter langres dimanche dans le
port de saldana à une centaine de
kilomètres au nord du cap alors pourquoi
saldana et bien certains experts pensent
qu'il pourrait utiliser les facilités de
stockage de saldana qui sont de
gigantesques facilité plus de 10
millions de barils de pétrole peuvent
être stockées là bas ce sont des idées
des facilités hérité du système de
l'apartheid au moment où il y avait
l'embargo alors est ce que l'afrique du
sud va aider la russie à stocker et peut
être à vendre son pétrole c'est la
question que l'opposition se pose elle
demande au gouvernement de clarifier
cette histoire
du sud fait le jeu de la russie notre
pays supportant un état paria alors que
le reste du monde seule la russie met en
place des sanctions l'afrique du sud est
devraient emboîter le pas mais
malheureusement il n'y a aucune loi qui
empêche l'afrique du sud les compagnies
sud-africaines ou étrangères basées en
afrique du sud d'acheter le pétrole
russe donc sur un plan légal nous
n'avons aucun recours mais sur le plan
moral on se doit de dire qu'il faut être
honnête à ce propos
l'afrique du sud est officiellement
neutre dans le conflit qui oppose la
russie à l'ukraine mais l'opposition a
demandé au ministre de l'énergie gwede
mantashe et de clarifier les positions
du gouvernement un débat est attendu
dans les semaines à venir au parlement
du cap
le g5 sahel est mort déclarations de
mohamed bazoum dans un entretien accordé
au quotidien la croix le président du
niger a également accusé les forces
maliennes de ne plus remplir leur
mission dans la zone des trois
frontières cette zone entre le niger le
mali et le burkina faso a été
l'épicentre de l'insurrection des
groupes liés à al qaïda et à l'état
islamique
on va rester au niger pour vous parler
de la déscolarisation des enfants avec
la croissance démographique la plus
rapide au monde le système éducatif est
sous pression dans le même temps à cause
de la pauvreté beaucoup d'enfants
quittent l'école très jeune pour des
boulots de survie reportage d'harold
gérard
ce jeune garçon au bonnet rouge vont des
petits sachets d'eau minérale dès 8
heures chaque jour il nous dit qu'il a
16 ans il en paraît très
la plupart du temps je fais une pause
pour manger et je reprends vers 14
heures et puis à la fin de la journée je
ne rentre à la maison qu'après la
première prière du soir vers 20 heures
comme beaucoup ces jeunes travailleurs a
été obligé très tôt de quitter l'école
pour aider sa famille financièrement une
situation qu'il préfère à l'inactivité
au niger 57 % des garçons entre 15 et 24
ans ne sont officiellement ni à l'école
ni au travail
mon oncle n'arrivait plus à payer les
frais de scolarité il n'avait pas
d'argent
et quand on allait à l'école on nous
chasse et jusqu à ce qu on utilise ce
n'est plus la peine de venir
les gouvernements successifs du pays
multiplient les politiques pour ramener
ses enfants à l'école et favoriser une
scolarisation plus longue mais même
lorsqu'ils dépassent le secondaire les
pressions liées à la pauvreté continue
d'handicaper des élèves en 2022 environ
50 mille jeunes sont à l'université à
travers le pays une partie des croches
systématiquement faute de moyens
c'est ça
c'est qui c'est qui compterait les
camarades forcément à chaud mais ne
pouvait aller à travailler gagner
quelque chose pour l'enseignant
chercheur en psychologie fatima mayaki
la pression familiale joue un rôle
majeur dans le décrochage scolaire des
nigériens
devenu grand donc il a atteint 2,7
enfants là un retour que le vietnam est
qu'ils ne supportent financièrement en
afrique subsaharienne universitaire est
une opportunité rare pour les jeunes en
2022 au moins 104 millions de personnes
y étaient déjà déscolarisés avant l'âge
de 18 ans
dans las de l'actualité en bref et en
images les enquêtes menées pour
déterminer la responsabilité de la mort
de trois manifestants nigérien au
passage d'un convoi de la force barkan
fin 2021 n'ont pas été concluantes le
niger et la france vont dédommager les
victimes ou leurs familles dix-sept
civils sept gendarmes nigériens et sept
militaires français avaient également
été blessés un tribunal de dakar a
reporté de quatre mois sa décision
contre le maire de dakar barthélémy dias
une décision rendue sous haute
protection policière
jugé en appel pour la mort d'un homme
tué par balle en 2011 dans un contexte
de violence politique l'arrêt de la cour
est très attendue en raison de ses
implications politiques
et puis le footballeur sénégalais
idrissa gueye sommé de s'expliquer le
conseil national de l'éthique de la
fédération française de football a écrit
aux joueurs du paris saint germain pour
lui demander d'expliquer si la wii ou
non refusé de participer à une opération
contre l'homophobie l'entourage du
milieu de terrain a annoncé qu'ils
réagiraient prochaine
au burkina faso de plus en plus de
jeunes créateurs ambitionne de faire de
ouagadougou une capitale émergentes de
la mode la ouaga fashion week s'est
récemment tenue dans la capitale après
deux ans de pause liés aux convives 19
mai l'événement a attiré moins de monde
que d'habitude
la faute notamment un contexte
sécuritaire tendu laurent berthet cher
un défilé de mode aux couleurs de
l'afrique pour cette troisième édition
de la world fashion week trente cinq
créateurs sont venus exhiber leurs
dernières collections et pour la
première fois plus de deux tiers sont
burkinabè symbole d'un secteur de la
mode en plein essor au burkina faso mais
aussi une conséquence de la situation
sécuritaire qui continue de se
détériorer
la qualité
de notre chiffre d'affaires et nos âmes
et ceux qui venaient l'aise et ceux qui
venaient de l'europe ne viennent plus
parce que il ya
peu depuis plusieurs mois le burkina
faso connaît une recrudescence des
violences qui à dist qui ont déjà fait
un million et demi de déplacés selon les
nations unies mais pour les
organisateurs de la ouaga fashion week
la crise sécuritaire est une raison de
plus de tenir ce défilé qui permet de
montrer le burkina faso sous un autre
angle et redorer l'image du pays il ya
des gens qui sont au franc entraîne de
mener une guerre pour que nous puissions
faire ce que nous nous faisons
actuellement donc je pense est une
obligation pour chaque burkinabè de
faire le mieux c'est qu'il sait le faire
pour tenir notre pays des baux au fait
pour ces jeunes créateurs burkinabè la
ouaga fashion week est l occasion de
montrer leur travail et de mettre à
l'honneur le faso danfani un tissu
traditionnel de la région
leur rêve que ouagadougou soit un jour
reconnu comme une capitale de la mode
africaine
le coureur cycliste binyam germées qui
s'est blessé à un oeil sur le podium
après sa victoire d'étape ne prendra pas
le départ de la 11e étape du giro
l'erythréen décidé de jeter l'épongé
après cet accident gerber a été soigné à
l'hôpital après avoir été touché au
niveau de l'oeil par le bouchon d'une
bouteille lors de la cérémonie
protocolaire de la 6e étape
on se quitte sur ces images de fidèles
au pèlerinage annuel de la ghriba sur
l'île de djerba dans le sud de la
tunisie organisé chaque année au 33e
jour de la pâque juive ce pèlerinage sur
deux jours est au coeur des traditions
des tunisiens de confession juive cela
fait deux ans que l'événement n'a pu se
tenir en raison de la pandémie due
qu'aux vide 19
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct
[Musique]